it's time to order in and prepare for a
feast because it's episode 7 of the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina and this
one should be a smashing good time
Sabrina and Harvey begin the episode on
a romantic night walk together
discussing their plans for the
Thanksgiving weekend Sabrina's not
planning much while Harvey's got a visit
from grandpa kinkle which means a lot of
huntin and shootin something that
catches Sabrina off-guard is Harvey's
more of a lover not a fighter
Sabrina invites Harvey in but renege
when she sees some freshly laid
intestines nailed to the front door and
Harvey leaves without a second thought
never change Harvey turns out witches do
celebrate Thanksgiving their version is
called feast of feasts and the Spellman
family has been selected to participate
the unholy holiday is meant to honor the
incredible sacrifice of sister Freya
back in the day was actually the
Greendale 14 living in the forest the
mortal men of Greendale had hunted all
the animals leaving no food for the
witches but before they starved Freya
sacrificed herself so the sisters could
eat by slitting her own throat and
letting the coven feast on her body
because that's what sisters are for
everyone's all like what a heartwarming
tale but Sabrina is all like WTF and
Ambrose says it's not unlike the Donner
Party which were a group of American
pioneers in the mid-1800s who survived
being snowbound by resorting to
cannibalism
so every year 14 families to represent
the 14 original women are selected to
volunteer one of their female members
and what is possibly the worst game of
drawing straws ever the winner being
offered up like a turkey for the Church
of the night to feast on the feast of
the feast is reflective of the Greek
myth of Theseus in the Minotaur where
seven boys and seven girls 14 in total
were selected to be sacrificed in a
labyrinth by a Minotaur as tribute since
Hilda's been excommunicated that leaves
only sabrina and zelda as candidates and
Zelda's volunteering that's that back at
Baxter high Sabrina's new BFF which Miss
Wardwell asked the kids to research
their family history she picks out
Harvey who's all like Dorado
after class Sabrina asks Wardwell if
she's ever heard of the feast of feasts
and if there's any way to opt-out of it
she says she'll do some research and
then mutters under her breath
evil plan to expose the King khals
history luckily Sabrina's pretty hard of
hearing today meanwhile Harvey's grandpa
Colonel Tigh from Battlestar Galactica
and Harvey uses this as an opportunity
to complete his family history
assignment grandpa reveals that the king
khals used to be the Vonk uncles and the
mines they owned were on land they took
from those people
he plans to fill Harvey and on how they
got rid of them when they go hunting
Suzy is also working on her assignment
diving into the family archives her
ex-demon Uncle Jesse kept she pulls out
a picture of Dorothea Putnam her
ancestor who came over to America from
Europe she'll come back again later in
the episode literally and Roz visits her
blind grandmother she mentioned she knew
Roz was worried about not having enough
faith due to grandmas cunning apparently
it's some sort of power the women in
their family gained a hunch or six cents
that helps them see things when others
do not the only price you pay is the
loss of your sight you've got the shimon
i mean shining Shh you want to get sued
at the academy prudence is pleased as
punch she's been volunteered to be part
of the feast lottery and Sabrina's like
for real but for prudence there's no
greater honor especially considering
she's an orphan
Sabrina then pulls Nick on his stance on
the feast and no one in the world would
be surprised to see he says exactly what
Sabrina wants to hear he thinks it's
bonkers apparently when Papa Spellman
was high priest he banned the feasts but
black would reinstate in it then Nick
gets super concern that he might be
having Sabrina for dinner
this gives Sabrina the idea that maybe
her aunt Zelda might turn around and the
whole feast thing if she was on the
chopping block so at the lottery as all
the family volunteers gathered just
before Zelda pulls her paper in barges
Sabrina she's gonna draw for the
Spellman family and in front of the eyes
of the whole coven Zelda capitulates so
much for operation change Zelda's mind
the women then pull their papers and
Sabrina's burns red while Prudence's
burns white all hail Queen prudence and
this which is like always a bridesmaid
never a bride
at home the Spellman's are grateful none
of them have to be eaten and we learned
that Sabrina's red burning paper means
she's going to be the handmaiden the
handmaidens role is to ensure the
Queen's every whim is indulged while the
coven fasts guess who's at the door its
Queen P who shares a sultry hello with
gross I guess Ambrose subscribes to more
publications than just a masculine shape
prudence will be staying with Sabrina
while she gets plumped up for feeding
time Sabrina treats prudence to my
Thursday night tradition of macaroons
and a buttermilk bath with rose petals
as Sabrina gets that tough spot on
Prudence's back she mentions that if
Prue wanted to escape Sabrina would look
the other way this baffles Prue being
queen of the feast is not unlike the
Aztec practice of human sacrifice to the
gods those sacrifice do so willingly for
a greater purpose
once the coven consumes her Prue will
become a part of everyone late that
night Sabrina who now has to sleep on
the floor wakes up after hearing some
noises from upstairs and up in Ambrose's
room everyone's gone all Caligula and
great Nick made it what the Queen wants
the Queen gets between us Sabrina Nick
come on man what kind of attempt was
that what do you think I'm going to say
to you No correct the next morning
prudence is feeling very refreshed and
Sabrina makes another attempt to
convince prude instead of being eaten
she'll take Prue to Baxter High which is
a lot of boys to torment and seduce
hopefully with a little more game than
Nick speaking of game Hawthorne's got a
thing for Ward well now that she's let
her hair down and brought her inner
demon out meanwhile Sabrina introduces
prudence to her friends Suzie brings up
her ancestor Dorothea apparently Suzie's
learned that Dorothea was an original
settler of Greendale and helped a group
of women flee religious persecution from
Scotland which has to be the Greendale
witches right Scotland is also a country
with a deep-rooted history of witch
trials dating back to the Middle Ages
where over 4000 alleged witches were
killed not to mention it's home to
famous witches including the three
witches of Macbeth prudence also seems
to know about Dorothea and looks upon
her as a hero
so Dorothea totally a witch Ally when
the topic changes to Harvey's history
prudence gets pissed our res ancestors
were witch hunters which makes a lot of
sense remember in episode 5 during
Sabrina's nightmare when the King khals
came in to hunt Sabrina next Sabrina and
prudence get a visit from Miss Wardwell
who Sabrina compels to talk some sense
into prove ward well mentions a witch
who is also Queen the feast but had
reason to reject it and now lives in the
woods that perhaps they should give her
a visit
prudence finds it hard to
leave that anyone would ever spurn
queenship so she's curious and Ward
Wells got something up her sleeve back
of the Spellman's Connors mom has come
to pick up her son's ashes and were
reminded that there's a witch killer
still on the loose there doesn't seem to
be any leads from the police but Connors
mom found a box with occult items inside
Ambrose asked if she could bring the
items and she agrees in the woods ward
well in the gang visit des Melda The
Witch of the woods who's got an
eye-popping story to tell
God does Melda says she never ran from
the Dark Lord but rather from her high
priest who used the feasts to violate
children in the coven what they're
trying to tell prudence is that father
Blackwood is asking her to do the feast
not the Dark Lord and her obligation is
only to him at the same time the kinkle
men are out for a hunt when they spotted
deer in the woods and since it's
Harvey's first hunt he should do the
honors as Sabrina and prove Duke it out
over Blackwood they hear the hunters
gunshot looks like the deer was actually
a familiar most likely des melda's to
hide the familiars body the witches form
a pentagram with yarn around it and put
up a cloaking spell and look who shows
up again we see Sabrina confronted with
her greatest fear that her mortal loved
ones will turn on her which infuriates
the weird sisters who want blood
atonement for the murdered familiar but
Sabrina still believes Harvey is not a
killer
ra's brings susie to visit her Nana and
Nana makes a weird comment the series so
far has seen Susie struggle with the
idea of gender identity
I think Nana's cunning has shown an
azusa's true self which identifies as
male she also mentions the history of
the cunning that it came from a witch's
curse blinding the women of the family
when Sabrina gets back from the woods
she finds Harvey who reveals he wasn't
the one who shot the deer the to embrace
and Sabrina seems to put a protection
spell on him a protection spell which
will likely come in handy considering
the end of this episode
inside Zelda recruit Sabrina to help
Lady Blackwood who's having trouble with
her pregnancy she's bleeding and has
high blood pressure
Zelda asked if she's done any heavy
spell casting lately - which lady
Blackwood says she had - and that
Sabrina would understand
she knows what they are really like and
that they are going to kill her babies
by they she means the weird sisters she
won't let them take what
Long's to her children so she acted
first take out one and the others are no
threat Dan the third trimester hysteria
sure is potent Zelda wonders if Lady
Blackwood thinks Fausta's has other
children outside of marriage he wouldn't
be the first high priest and bastard
children born to a high priest are just
as eligible to the seat as those who are
legitimate prudence is actually the
daughter of Faustus Blackwood so Lady
Blackwood wants her out of the picture
to protect her unborn children and
Sabrina has a plan to get her talking at
Suzy's she gets a visit from her
ancestor Dorothea well asleep but
something tells me it's more than just a
dream that night handmaiden Sabrina
hosts the black woods and prudence for
the queen of the feast Last Supper while
Wardwell decides she's having pizza boy
for Thanksgiving Hilda has prepared a
cake that will get lady Blackwood
spilling the truth the black woods dig
in and Sabrina begins her questioning a
minute later and Lady Blackwood is
revealing her plot against prudence it
comes out that Lady Blackwood rigged the
ballot box and Faustus who also ate the
cake confirms he is Prudence's father
whose mother killed herself when he
wouldn't marry her that's why he's kept
her so close but only prudence the other
sisters are still just orphans
Sabrina then blackmails Blackwood to end
the feast of feasts for good and save
prudence at the official feast the coven
is getting hangry for some prudence and
have been fasting for days
Faustus comes in and bears the bad news
to the coven that prudence can no longer
fulfill her duty as queen of the feast
and just as he's about to say the feast
is canceled missus always a bridesmaid
never a bride pulls a fray and slits her
own throat for the coven to feast on the
crowd goes wild with hunger and digs in
and Oh Oh God Ambrose and Luke hang out
away from the feast as one is under
house arrest in the other well I just
plain don't trust him when Hilda walks
in with some bad news there are two more
bodies on the way suicides
Connors mum and dad looks like someone
got to them before Ambrose could get his
hands on Connors occult box after the
feast Zelda clearly shaken tells Sabrina
she would never have let her be
sacrificed Harvey and Tommy head into
the mines for some sweet sweet holiday
pay and look to have a nice relaxing
shaft
I mean shift shift but the orphan duo
brought their voodoo dolls
and they have something else in mind
thanks everyone for watching and for the
great support and comments I've been
getting for these videos make sure to
LIKE and subscribe we only have three
more videos to get to before being done
with the season until next time keep
walking that path of night